okay how's it going bros my name is here
back and we're gonna play facade this is
classical amazing game it looks so old
and [ __ ] my you know my entire
computer just change opening this [ __ ]
it's like have to initiate 1995 mode
okay please choose your name Sam
apparently I would broke penis but
apparently that's Samsa and the loadings
are ridiculous are they fighting firing
on me okay can I go or what yes it's
true it's so true Bronski what yeah come
in a sec while I go get grace so how do
I enter help me I'm stuck
are you guys having sex
hey yeah that's how you spell it
enjoy yourself
without me can I go in or what huh oh hi
there
so I'm so funny by the way
yeah you look fabulous are you remember
the wonderful that what Sam oh I can
move it oh hey guys sorry I didn't
realize I can move how you doing
anyway how you can't remember I'm gonna
fix us some drinks
yay our friends here we can let the
answering machine did it
yeah that's answering whatever again
anyhow Tripps parents yes Oh Tripp she's
just here you there it's good your
mother that once and I haven't heard
from you and grace in a while uh-huh
okay
by Travis I don't oh there it is come
over here and sit on the couch with no
I'm looking at the friggin Prada
hold on now yes Sam what does this
picture make you think I'm good
well actually this trip to Italy was
meant to be our second honeymoon trip
don't exaggerate it was simple yeah yeah
our second honeymoon picture says
Venus
now
what they want from me it says what I
don't pound whatever you're annoying I'm
just gonna go over here and talk to
Tripp darling your obsession with that
photo is making our friend uncomfortable
yeah yeah romance
it says romance where you know
oh I didn't think you want tell me
something tonight
they're so confusing I don't even I
don't I don't want to get Stefano that's
not the father I'm ready good father
oh do you like those sculptures yeah
it's supposed to be so into opening
collecting that I am stefano into them
you love your sculpture so much i'm not
even allowed to touch them I touch that
Sam I want some why not right wine wine
wine wine wine wine wine I want wine no
give me the mind give me wine no woman
one kiss kiss me come here I guess me
okay
are you know I am you know what I think
you should leave uh-uh
nah nah there's only so much you can
expect laughs you know I'm staying now
don't give me that let me fine you just
have to go at least I have that wine
fine I don't need you yeah okay or maybe
it did go well I I don't even know it's
like okay yeah I hope you enjoyed I'll
might play more tomorrow
but he doesn't like Wow oh that Natomas
give me Latin Adam um I don't care I
don't care I don't care my haters gonna
hate
I'll laugh cuz you're fake I